[Musique]
on est en train de travailler sur une
pièce qui s'appelle la terre sous les
ongles qui est une pièce tout public à
partir de 7 ans
cette pièce traite dans ce sujet très
particulier parce qu'on voulait aborder
pour les tout-petits la notion de la
mort et du deuil
sur scène on aura deux interprètes
comédiens qui peut danser et une
danseuse qui peut faire de la comédie
[Musique]
on s'est aperçu qu'en fait plus les
enfants jeunes étaient outillés en fait
et entendait parler de ce que c'était
que la mort peu importe les religions de
ce que c'est que les étapes du deuil etc
plus étaient outillés plus tard le jour
où ils vont être traversés par une
épreuve pareille ils pourront la
traverser avec beaucoup plus de de
d'expérience on va dire on va pleurer on
va être au colère on va être voilà dans
le déni tout ça mais je pense que le
prisme de l'humour nous a permis
d'aborder ce sujet là sans trop sans
trop de complication
[Musique]
Alexis bah du coup comme on l'avait pas
fait encore avec le manteau faut que tu
exagères un peu le
faut que tu exagères un peu le bassin
quand tu es ici quand tu vois la balle
faut que ce soit
il faut que ça remonte un petit peu dans
le dans l'excitation dans cette pièce la
comédienne ne parle pratiquement pas
elle parle pas parce que dans une des
étapes du deuil on voit que il y a des
gens qui peuvent être complètement
bloqués au niveau de la parole plus
pouvoir parler de leur émotion se faire
mais complètement au monde toutes ces
choses là en fait donc c'est important
pour nous de voilà de symboliser un peu
ce côté là de de de comment on vit la
mort de quelqu'un donc à ce moment là on
s'est dit il fallait absolument ben
qu'elle prenne l'espace autrement
qu'elle existe autrement et et voilà et
la danse c'était c'était évident et
notre travail il est vraiment autour du
physique du mouvement et de la comédie
en fait quoi
[Musique]